[Musique]
je m'appelle de dette je te ferai une
grande danseuse étoile des preuves
[Applaudissements]
j'étais moi et apprend la rigueur
t'oublie pas de ces gilbert qui va me
chercher
gilbert merci d'avoir un outil pour vous
ce temps p
c'est gilbert ils partent à la montagne
proposent en mode - l'annoncé de ses
parents ça nous d'essayer des poils je
me demandais si tu voudrais pas jouer à
la poupée avec moi par contre l'ia
personnes
[Musique]
vos parents jamais doute plane en effet
pas de ses proches docteur leur fait
confiance on parle pas beaucoup je pense
qu'ils s'appellent toi vedette la fin
respecter la merde merde
manu c'est mon meilleur ami gay rire
mais grave ici il est déjà 18 heures
souk
ok il un obèse qui s'impatientent ya pas
de petit tout le monde est jetée comme
puis face à l'amour vous fier aux
gentils en fait non pas deux comme moi
je vais en profiter je vais pas raconter
à l'homme que j'aime les viols que j'ai
subie quand j'étais môme
quand on aime on est capables de
construire des choses non non c'est un
conte de fées ça il est salvateur de
parler de ce qui vous est arrivé en prêt
à les détruire la vie de mes parents
leur mig est le meilleur ami de la
famille
ok quand tu étais petit tu t'es pris ce
monsieur que l'amérique à cet ouvrage
c'est qu'un souvenir
pourquoi tu m'a rien dit je sais pas
comment ça tu sais pas ça c'est pas pour
ils vont réagir les gens
[Musique]
je sais ce que j'ai suivie aujourd'hui
le ça sorte
c'est mon mari a été rien moi maintenant
et tout ces deux bons
toi c'est uniquement en dhr
[Musique]